hello and welcome to drive at the motor
magazine on DW this time new SUV from
Japan we test the Mitsubishi Eclipse
cross backing up with ease
thanks to VW's trailer assistant and the
latest from the LA Auto Show
this year's Los Angeles Auto Show as
always is a showcase for American brands
like Cadillac and GMC here you'll see
huge cruisers and brawny pickups with
plenty of power under the hood just what
Americans like best
some of the best known examples are the
RAM truck and the Lincoln Navigator
but other renowned manufacturers are
showing off their latest models in LA to
her CBC M she had Tobias MERS points out
California is the u.s. as biggest car
market la is one of the most significant
automobile shows in America and deadly
flattened head of marketing for Porsche
says his company loves la love affair
here's how Porsche presents its new
dynamic duo the 718 Boxster GTS and the
718 Cayman GTS are the top models in
their ranges complain who says that
despite all the talk about connectivity
and digitalization many customers want
something pure unfiltered and analog one
of us police teachers vessel was it busy
it is can see Tamara an Alok Porsche
wants to cater to those desires with the
new 911 carrera t luring the purists are
its reduced weight manual transmission
and mechanical rear differential lock
meanwhile Toyota has a new version of
the Camry this compact mid-range sedan
has been around since 1983 and although
it is a top seller in much of the world
it's not on offer in Europe
Toyota's luxury car division Lexus is
drawing attention with the new edition
of its RX 350 l customers had clamored
for a third row of seats and here Lexus
has provided it mercedes-benz has
brought several highlights to Los
Angeles first the s-class convertible
the open four seater is the lap of
luxury and profits from the developments
in the hardtop s-class models
highlight number two is the third
generation of the CLS
that's kind Percy these chief designer
Gordon Wagoner says everything is new in
the third generation of the CLS which
created a design icon and a new class of
four-door coupe A's this is the first
time that a car has been permitted to
look like a design sketch the way
designers draw them the enthusiasts with
a small roof and an exaggeratedly flat
silhouette that makes this car
spectacular spectacular the COS is being
released with a completely new selection
of three six-cylinder engines two
diesels and a gasoline
proceeded easy mg's project one is
heading in an entirely different
direction
versus the one displays all the
technologies that is currently feasible
its 1.6 liter v6 engine was adopted from
a Formula One race car for electric
motors give this speedster more power a
total of 745 kilowatts allow it to reach
speeds above 350 kilometers an hour
not quite that fast but still very
sporty a Chevrolet's classic Corvette
but the tradeshow offers more than
concept cars and mass-produced vehicles
here you can also see one-of-a-kind
creations like this Kia stinger souped
up by the tuning pros of West Coast
Customs and here's a concept snowmobile
based on a GMC pickup truck it has a
rack for snowboards and it's chains
allow it to tackle the mountains
if you want a really eccentric an
extravagant ride try this to seat three
wheel buggy it's sure to catch eyes and
turn heads
car tester Michelle says Mitsubishi has
been out of the headlines for a while
but now it's new models shows they've
been keeping us eclipse cross is the
name of the Japanese manufacturers new
compact SUV it's not an unknown name
with over 1.4 million units sold over
four generations and 20 years until 2012
the Eclipse was a very successful sports
car especially in North America the
eclipse cross takes on the coupe a light
contour of its namesake and transfers
the sporty silhouette into the SUV
segment Michelle says the Mitsubishi
Eclipse cross provides a good feel for
the road with very soft and comfortable
steering thanks to the continuously
variable transmission there are no
abrupt gear shifts the four-cylinder
gasoline engine delivers a respectable
120 kilowatts and goes to work with up
to 250 Newton meters of torque but at
the same time the Eclipse cross is big
and heavy and although the CVT
transmission is one of the best of its
kind it seems to swallow a lot of power
the car just doesn't feel lively and
even under optimum test conditions it
needs 7 litres of fuel per 100
kilometers
it's a business Schell says Mitsubishi
has deliberately chosen a design that
will polarize buyers
she says she finds the rear to be a bit
too angular but the front is more
successful it's abhi she's last few cars
were also bland that they were instantly
forgettable but the Eclipse crust looks
like it's trying hard to get our
attention perhaps too hard its side
profile is sleek and sporty and at 4.41
meters relatively long with its split
rear window and high mounted lights the
quirky rear makes competitors like a
Nissan Juke and BMW x4 look almost
ordinary
the rear seats can be moved forward 20
centimeters the split rear seats can be
moved separately from each other and
have adjustable pitch this makes the
cross extremely flexible when space is
needed Michelle says she likes the
interior a lot especially because
Mitsubishi isn't known as a luxury
manufacturer but the interior really
doesn't look cheap and there's a good
feel to the materials they used the
dashboard is horizontally split
following a philosophy of information
above operation below what's striking is
this black square in the center console
next to the gear lever for the first
time Itza be she has equipped a model
with a touchpad that's a feature
previously available only in hire
vehicle classes functions like the radio
and the apple carplay system can be
intuitively controlled with your finger
a paddle on the steering wheel controls
the behavior of the continuously
variable transmission
she says the Eclipse cross closes the
gap between Mitsubishi's ASX and its
Outlander the company has a long history
of off-road vehicles and sees itself as
an all-terrain specialist she says that
tradition doesn't always have to look a
little fashioned there are no obvious
weaknesses in the first kilometers of
our test omits abhi she's lifestyle SUV
its handling is quite dynamic without
sacrificing comfort it's also safe
thanks to all the latest connectivity
and a variety of assistance and germany
the mitsubishi eclipse cross starts at
just under 22 thousand euros
the new SEAT Leon Cupra R is the current
top-of-the-range Cupra and with 228
kilowatts it's the Spanish makers most
powerful model its top speed is
electronically limited at 250 km/h but
it also packs a powerful price and
Germany that starts at just under 45,000
euros the second-generation Dacia Duster
is set to hit the streets on the outside
it stayed tough with some minor visual
tweaks but the interior has been
completely redesigned it's been given a
big safety boost with a blind-spot
warning system the da Chia Duster goes
on the market in early 2018
Frankfurt Airport is one of Europe's
most important air traffic hubs every
day it handles almost 1300 takeoffs and
landings and more than 165 thousand
passengers
all the airborne and earthbound
operations have to function
absolutely smoothly to keep the rampant
succession of takeoffs and landings on
schedule
that's a mammoth task even when the
weather is good imagine the challenge
when ice and snow cover the runways if
just 10 centimeters of snow fall on the
ramps taxiways and runways then about
six thousand truckloads of snow have to
be removed
this is what a fast cost-effective
solution could look like Mercedes new
remote truck interface system
coordinates vehicles unclosed company
sites to operate as automated convoys
yummy I'm here fiha here for automated
our Rock truck says Philip dryer of
Daimler's lab 1886 they been automated
for removing snow from the airport
runways they are remote control and a
differential GPS system locates them on
the airfield that means that in addition
to the normal GPS system familiar from
navigation devices there is a local
correction system up on the tower of the
testing grounds it refines the GPS
reading so that the snow removal trucks
are steered within a tolerance of
centimeters
remotes truck interface is a step toward
a completely networked and autonomous
utility vehicle the system was developed
in collaboration with specialists from
the company that operates Frankfurt
Airport no special sensors are involved
they wouldn't work in bad weather anyway
communication between the vehicles and
the operators is by encoded radio signal
listen Philip Dreyer explains that the
automation of these snow removal trucks
has two aspects first they drive
themselves acceleration braking and
steering are carried out with a central
control unit second another central unit
controls the snow removal equipment it's
operated by a person in the lead vehicle
what's new here is that the operator and
the lead vehicle is not a driver there's
no need to steer a break
allowing closer supervision of the
convoys operations in kind father is son
and a bhakta knew or didn't believe this
convoys as a length neeterb fence nice
Anandi Bai Bo box-and-one snow removal
at Frankfurt Airport cost 23 million
euros last winter the weather services
snow predictions often turn out to be
false alarms the advantages of the
remote truck interface system are rapid
and flexible use of the vehicles and
high precision this system could be
useful also on construction sites when
clearing minefields and ocean harbors
and in agriculture the system works only
on closed grounds but has proved to be
very reliable all that still lacking is
a test under severe snow conditions
I know Tyson over says for many drivers
parking a vehicle with a horse trailer
attached to it is no laughing matter
heavens but he says VW's trailer assist
should help it's the system promoted in
this commercial with the Laughing horses
though when a VW tiguan with trailer
assist arrives
the party's over ABBA
but does the system really help while
driving a vehicle with a trailer
attached let's see he says as a compact
SUV the Tiguan is well suited to this
task it boasts high ground clearance and
robust plastic cladding that offers good
underbody protection
and thanks to its all-wheel drive the
vehicle maintains a firm grip even on
slippery surfaces
horse lover Sophie health is going to
test what the Tiguan is like as a tow
vehicle she flips the switch in the
trunk to release the trailer hitch then
she uses the rear view camera to
maneuver the trailer precisely
does esteemeth final says trailer assist
is easy to use and a big help when
reversing though he advises drivers to
practice a little in a parking lot first
still it's only a driver assist and not
a completely automated system he feels a
computer can never completely replace a
human's visual judgment
it takes just a few quick steps to
connect the electrical cable that
delivers power to the trailers
taillights secure it and turn the crank
to the lock snaps into place and
Sophie's all ready to go for a test
drive our Tiguan is equipped with a 2
litre 110 kilowatt diesel engine though
it's the smallest diesel engine
available for this SUV it packs plenty
of pulling power its maximum 340 Newton
metres of torque at just 1750 rpm mean
it can pull away with ease even with a
trailer in tow
now comes the decisive part of the test
Sophie must back the trailer into a
designated parking spot Jovie explains
that she first put the car into reverse
like normal then she presses the Park
Assist button to activate the trailer
assist now she steers the car using the
mirror adjustment joystick by pushing it
to the left or right depending on the
direction she wants to go no she wants
to go left
so she presses left words
trailer assists relies on many
components that are already present Park
Assist power steering electric mirror
adjustment the rear-view camera and the
infotainment display all of these
components work together to prevent the
trailer from suddenly ending up in the
wrong place
Sophie says that at first it was a bit
strange to steer the car and the tree
there using just the little mirror
adjustment button but once you've done
it a few times it's relatively easy
especially because you can see the
direction you're going on this
infotainment display here Rhino says the
good news is trailer Assist works
straightaway the bad news is it costs
extra and you need to combine components
to make it work for instance the
rear-view camera and the trailer hitch
with the electrical installation kit the
system cost nine hundred thirty five
euros and the trailer hitch another
eight hundred eighty but trailer assist
does give drivers a sense of security so
they can relax when they're pulling a
big load even in tight spaces or
situations with poor visibility backing
up is no longer a problem
today the Porsche 356 numbers among the
truly classic sports cars in 1948 it
became the first automobile to proudly
bear the porsche name before then
Ferdinand Porsche had developed cars for
various other brands at the porsche
design and engineering firm he'd founded
in 1931 and stood gun
they ask the faucet but our classic car
expert christoph bauer tells us that the
first porsche wasn't actually built in
stuttgart but in the austrian town of
Jamuna near the end of the Second World
War the company had moved its entire
operations there to escape the constant
bombing raids and the 356 wasn't the
brainchild of patriarch ferdinand
porsche rather it was his son ferry who
created the sports car out of VW parts
his father priest ferries work and said
he wouldn't change a single screw
Ferdinand Porsche was one of the auto
industry's pioneers starting in 1897 he
developed electric and hybrid vehicles
an all-electric drive model and
trend-setting mid-engined race cars like
the Ostrow Daimler Sasha and the Auto
Union Silver Arrow
by then Christophe tells us that early
versions of the Porsche 356 had a
souped-up beetle engine under the hood
which barely produced 40 horsepower
that's not really enough for a sports
car but he says it's fun all the same
the car is clever aerodynamics and
lightweight construction let it reach
140 kilometres an hour
Zubov annotate on two fallacies cut
divine organs windows walls work
during the 17 years the 356 was produced
Porsche continued to make improvements
this super 90 convertible from 1960 is
among the most fully perfected versions
its 1.6 liter 90 horsepower engine is
over twice as powerful as the motor in
the original 356
as an importer feels that the Porsche
356 is not only a blast to drive it's a
feast for the senses - the bakelite
steering wheel the leather seats these
buttons here everything gives you the
impression of being made to last the
cars body was designed by engineer Aaron
commenda who'd already given shape to
auto unions Grand Prix sports cars and
the VW Beetle christophe says the 356 is
a true milestone in automotive history
that formed the basis for Porsches
design language he says any new 911 is
really just a modern variant of the 356
mr. Anglin East analyst animal Diana but
he entered aesthetics Infiniti
it's face is immediately recognizable
the round headlights and prominent wings
have essentially become part of Porsches
DNA that gently sloping rear is also a
Porsche specialty
although the teardrop aerodynamic design
is now seen as dated the ignition is
found to the left of the steering wheel
the tachometer is centrally located and
the ergonomics are stellar these
features Porsche drivers have come to
know and love all came from the 356
that's Cristo says the heart of the 356
can be found back here while the first
356 is used beetle engines this one was
already fitted with a four-cylinder 1.6
liter Porsche boxer engine boosts under
head cams and generates 90 horsepower in
part thanks to these two Solex
carburetors the standard engines had 60
and 75 horsepower
there was a 130 horsepower variant with
a very complicated vertical shaft engine
but he says this here is the finest one
you can get
the boxer engines are viewed as reliable
and long-lasting then as now Porsches
are often known as sensible sports cars
which makes them unique christophe says
that when Porsche announced it would be
introducing a successor model fans and
automotive journalists claimed that a
new Porsche could never outdo the old
356 well the 911 has certainly made more
than a few friends over the years and as
the forefather to the 911
the first Porsche ever the 356 is
definitely an automotive milestone Stein
today it's still a pleasure to take a
356 convertible out for a spin on the
picture s roads of Trentino in northern
Italy after the 356 was discontinued in
1965 porsche buyers had to wait until
1982 for the introduction of the 911
convertible until they could once again
feel the wind in their hair
next time on drive it a pickup from
Mercedes we put the new ex class to the
test and natural gas in the tank
VW takes a new look at this alternative
fuel
you